prepare
for two
[Applause]
[Music]
rebels with a cause
if you'd like it you should have put a
ring pop on and you know what i'm saying
you think genghis khan would stand for
this
phoenix
houston
charleston nashville new york baltimore
the rebels with a cause comedy tour
tickets on sale now at
louderwithcrowder.com
tour
[Music]
i knew you'd come back
thank god
anybody wants a mug club
hopper
cause 99 a year 69 for students in the
active military oh come on quarter black
i don't need that i can't laugh right
now so you you haven't seen the puppy
oh come on no i was
i was waiting to see you together i seen
the kid kid's a winner he's got a head
just like you hobble
oh there she is now
look at it there's your big brother
is that it
oh hopper i can't believe it she's
really ours thank you oh come on now
you've done all the work hopper
i can't believe you've done this hey
believe me we did
oh no
she ain't got a name
what do we call her hopper betty's a
great name
yeah i bet he's a pretty good name
yeah but betty's okay
oh hop she's the best i've ever seen you
really done good
you really done good oh you look so
tired
why don't you save that gross thing
ah no no offer i feel great i feel great
listen i was thinking if you don't want
me mixing around on youtube no more you
know you don't want no more the mohammed
cartoons or the [ __ ] jokes
i was thinking
maybe i'm not gonna do the show
you know we can make some other way
there's one thing i want you to do for
me what is that come here what
bring the show back
[Music]
bring the show back
what are we waiting for i'm on retainer
here
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
oh
[Music]
honey
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yogurt
[Music]
there you go
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
stranger
[Music]
oh i just chipped a tooth see what i
just did it's because i was
i was lowering
my seat
with this in my mouth with this and this
this
wow
well it hurts
i am thor uh glad to be with you today
uh i forgot that old intro that we did
we i know as many people say when they
see hopper in there but joe lewis is
here he's great he fills the spot he's
not in the studio today because he
doesn't like all the noise is he the pup
no that was betty oh that was betty yeah
betty's a pup betty cannot be in the
studio she will destroy everything
glad to be we have so much to get to by
the way really quickly before anything
else the tickets are selling fest we're
expanding uh houston and phoenix just so
you know the smart financial center in
houston and i guess it's the financial
arena in phoenix live earthquaker.com
slash tour
what's going on there casey is there
something uh
okay you can go buy your tickets there
uh right now and by the way for people
who are talking about this some other
people are scalping them they go to
other places like oh it's 300 tickets
that is not us nope at all just to be
clear people buy tickets and they sell
them at a premium
so
we're sorry about that but there's
nothing we can do we'll be talking about
a lot here today uh nancy pelosi may be
flying to taiwan but maybe i mean
absolutely do you think that puts the
united states uh citizen at risk you you
can comment below uh also we'll be
talking about monkey pox i don't know if
you know about this oh and we just took
out one of the taliban's top officials
which is a big thing today uh we're
gonna give you also by the way
because we're not
we're not without a heart here we want
to help you
tell you how to avoid the monkey pox
[Music]
no spoiler alert sorry
before we get to that gerald a how are
you i am doing very well no monkey pox
no monkey i'm clear and then you know
him you love him at landau dave dave
landau ahoy you good you feeling a
little better not really no
okay yeah it's rocking you fake it until
you make it that's right as they say i'm
on the o z pack that's how uh you know
that some we're still waiting on cory
booker to fake that he doesn't have a
lazy eye yes
or to find seltzer yes the fact that he
doesn't have monkeys oh well careful
hold on
some news of stelter uh we don't want it
yeah you know we don't want to celebrate
and uh you know um
the dead so
before we hit anything else here today
uh drone strike okay this just happened
uh precision strike as they say yeah on
the news so uh monday august 1st uh the
former vice president joe biden
announced the death of
ayaman al-zau zawahiri okay he's one of
the one of the top al qaeda leaders so
that's a big thing this is big news
this is a good thing just to be clear
credit where it's due i am happy
that this piece of crap is dead
um here let's roll the clip of uh former
vice president joe biden letting us know
you know we we
we make it clear again tonight
that no matter how long it takes
no matter where you hide
if you are a threat to our people do you
know our people find you
and take you out
after relentlessly seeking zawahiri for
years under presidents bush obama and
trump
our intelligence community located
zawahiri earlier this year
it moved to downtown kabul to reunite
with members of his immediate family
seriously after carefully considering
a clear and convincing evidence of his
location
i authorized a precision strike that
would remove him from the battlefield
once and for all yes he authorized it
like ben affleck authorized the script
of good will hunting yes
put my put my name on there he got him
at that good ripe age of 72. yes exactly
that's a great age to catch a terrorist
did we say do we say percentage straight
we meant tooth decay yes yes no look
he's three days from heart disease
you're gonna find his liver with white
spots on it all right i think we all
agree this is a good thing yes of course
you guys can comment below i'm not a fan
of former vice president joe biden but
of course
i'm happy that this guy was taken out
i'm happy that he's dead
scumbag
this is something that you would think
all everyone in this country could be on
board with however
cnn just in tripping over their johnson
uh to make sure that they could just
somehow turn this into a loss
decided to pivot and let us know that
this was not
the most important narrative at hand
regarding the killing of a notre
terrorist we don't talk enough about how
domestic extremists are also harming our
country equally as big of a threat as
well and i think it's important to note
you know the stories that we now cover
of the parents from gun violence our
black churches and our synagogues i
think that's also warrants equal
attention we're talking about threats
against america it is a really
interesting changing landscape that i
think is worth the discussion
it's not interesting and it's not a
changing landscape
[Laughter]
al qaeda has been a real problem for
some time yeah you would think so but
you know what uh she just saw uh
american history x rerunning on tbn yeah
that's true i was like oh boy oh
deserves equal you can't have a bunch of
ed furlongs and bomber jackets running
around not not at all i mean it's
comparable to thousands of people dead
on 911 the the sailors killed on the uss
cole the bombings at the marine barracks
i think 100 and maybe around 150 dead
about the billions of dollars in arms
and helicopters those are roughly the
same why didn't you just say listen uh
we need to blame white people yeah yes
it would have been more to the point
by the way i love where they found this
guy where was he hiding in a cave
somewhere like in a spider hole was it
just like the guy you know the saddam
hussein no no no he was in an apartment
airbnb in downtown kabul he was at bob
evans in afghanistan like what did you
see the airbnb it was like a mansion
nice very nice it was very nice he was
staying in peter gallagher's house in
the oc
i'm also amazed they started because he
was retired
they shot two missiles at this guy and
only killed him in a very highly
populated area of like
what kind of missiles were these these
shots they were precision and here's the
thing this is why the this is why the
left the democrats are so disconnected
very american public just to be clear
everyone here should be celebrating this
win this is one of people often say hey
we're more divided than ever well why do
you think that is
why do you think it is why do you think
we're more divided than ever you think
it's because of the response to that you
think it's because of us responding to
cnn is it the fault of the people
defending their good names i say a
second we're actually not nearly that
much of a problem and by them i don't
mean actual white supremacists who
should be condemned totally remember
that one yeah i'm talking about american
citizens where you want to say that the
domestic extremism and then by the way i
should note after this unseen and they
spent an entire segment on uh on uh
the insurrection ah really january 6th
hmm most violent attack on our capital
ever violence seven or eight other ones
yes where one person died who was uh not
on the right and not armed who was
unarmed that's what they did next and
they weren't even presenting an original
segment they were talking about don
lemon discussing that topic the night
before
she said
and this is the issue this is where the
divider and this is why i say it's not a
bad thing and i will not apologize and
neither should you for pointing out lies
where people just say you're sewing
discord what are you supposed to do what
are you supposed to do when once upon a
time it's true we all would have been
united great terrorist dead and then cnn
says but we need to be
we need to be mindful that
just as great of a threat if not greater
and by that
it's the opposite of the truth right
yeah not at all even remotely the same
level of threat but according to cnn it
just as great of a threat if not greater
is
black churches and synagogues because of
domestic extremists
what are you supposed to do just let
that go unchecked you know they're not
going to be checked by snopes you know
they're not going to be checked by wapo
by reuters
and then they want to blame you for the
disconnect so just understand and don't
play into the narrative when they say
civility and by they i mean the
progressive left the leftists in the
united states what they mean is shut up
and take it they only care about
civility when it's their people in power
was there civility when george bush was
in power was there civility when donald
trump was in power of course not keep
fighting keep holding their feet to the
fire and be happy doing it you can be a
happy warrior look
for reference i've been doing this a
long time when barack obama was
president
and osama bin laden was killed
you came down to me joe because you
thought i celebrated too much a little
bit
i was incredibly happy i was absolutely
thrilled and i even did a video
immediately afterward not criticizing
obama uh i think it was uh we have this
from was it 2010 2000 this was on my
youtube channel back then uh osama bin
laden in hell hello hello from the
afterlife
more specifically
hell
i know i was as surprised as you
i didn't even realize it when i first
got here because it was not any
different from pakistan
it only hit me when i saw nero accusing
karl marx of cheating at pickup sticks
satan notified me that it was a navy
seal who'd taken me out in my pakistani
compound and that my death was kind of a
big deal
please pay no mind to the pictures in
the news if i'd have known that i'd be
having company i would have cleaned up
speaking of satan he is not what i
expected
he kind of looks like if brendan fraser
and the young walter matthau had a baby
it was also informative very surprised
he can have his gun there
uh no bullets by the way back then it
took everything i had to scrape together
for that airsoft gun
and that was it i was very happy
we all were sealed team six i mean i
thought that barack obama was taking a
little too much credit for it
considering that steel team six did it
yeah i think it's the case with any
military operation but still
great
today cnn says we need to focus our
attention on people at home
domestic terrors domestic terrorists and
what do they mean by that you okay
speaking of cnn this is not something
that uh uh brings any any joy uh at all
i know he's sort of been uh i would say
a worthy and unworthy adversary here to
a lot of crowder um and it seems that
monkey box may have claimed another
victim really haven't seen him in a
while um so we actually do want to give
an honorable send off he passed away
sadly brian stelter
i have been waiting to share something
with all of you for the past six months
it was late at night which is why i was
getting ready to grapple with gay and
transgender people so that's really
where the story begins time to
close
[Music]
he's not dead
so
oh he's he's alive
we need to are you sure about that
because i have it on good authority the
researchers let us know yeah that's
that's that's beyond the pale for us yes
i didn't know i have you seen him he's
have you seen him i haven't seen him
that i mean that's a fair not since he
got what he's been calling pride pox
yeah
he's alive all right well look then if
that's the case and i don't know that it
is i apologize oh that's our bad anyone
could have made that mistake i thought
you looked i'm happy
i'm happy is he happy and healthy i i
mean for stelter i'm not talking about
bmi but is he healthy he's happy he's
alive
you're right okay there's no chance that
he's a down low brother that ended up
getting the box none
just to be clear we apologize that's our
bad you can fact check us in the
comments section below i'm still not
convinced hey by the way in case we are
not on uh you never know how long we're
on youtube that's true uh this is a live
show monday through thursday 10 a.m
eastern that's the best way to find us
tune in monday through thursday 10am
eastern you can watch it here on youtube
on rumble you can watch the mug club
where we do an entire hour of additional
programming today we're playing a
pokemon or hate symbol
and of course you can get it on spotify
you can get it uh or racial slurp
whatever it says here you certainly
can't do that it says here is monkey
crocs that are shaped like bananas so
that may have been well no it's they're
comfy yeah it's a kid's book box on cox
yes
it's a pop-out
sure hey let's move on now to uh before
we get to taiwan and pelosi and and the
actual news regarding the monkey pox
first let's check in with california
some new changes what's on in california
[Music]
so in case you didn't know about this uh
california
sucks you're gonna fact check me on that
gerald no
confirm yeah california is a terrible
place um and because of the largely
anti-police movement the allowing
homeless people to go this is one thing
when i was in spokane yeah and i've seen
all these homeless people there smoking
crack right outside of the rite aid in
broad daylight yeah listen
los angeles spokane seattle portland
austin san francisco do you ever just
take inventory of your cities of your
states do you ever just say you know
what detroit we've been doing it this
way for 40 50 60 years
hasn't made it any better have you
helped your homeless
are they better off because of it
so california is of course gathering i
mean at least we have good winters in
detroit that takes care of a lot of that
well that's true
those elevator shafts are uh they're
worth a pretty penny i'm just saying if
you can survive a detroit winner you can
at least get a job at mcdonald's you
would think so but no
can't pass the pistol
so gavin newsom's california is a
lawless wasteland of course and uh now
its citizens
are
as you'll see paying the price
[Music]
already on the ground mrs wren is kicked
squarely in the face they use the fist
to hit my head multiple times
[Music]
oh
i love here's the outside view of his
buddy
[Music]
they
just a few more
shotgun tote and grandpas and it might
improve yeah you would hope so or you
know rooftop koreans the point is i want
to see more like that last clip and less
like the former but unfortunately in
places like the uk and places like
canada and how they would like to see it
in california again if democrats had
power completely unfettered you would be
arrested for protecting your own
property and your own person so
there you go in case you thought that it
was uh the golden state it's just crap
[Music]
all right big story right now and we'll
keep you abreast as uh the story
continues to unfold here pelosi
a little foreshadowing the literary
technique that i used i'm a child in the
spoken word
um
nancy pelosi is uh is uh expected to
land at the songshan airport in taipei
at 10 40 yeah p.m and you guys can
comment below i want to hear
what do you where do you line up on this
do you think this is poking the bear
with china i mean poking the tiny little
uh yeah the the the panda what happens
we can pull that uh flight tracker up if
you want to see is it working because it
crashed earlier so many people are
trying to watch no i had it before the
show now it's
is it off now oh i might have refreshed
again i think oh wait we actually we do
we have a visual on our plane now yeah
of pelosi's plane
oh wow that's uh you know i hear there's
almost no carbon footprint because it's
fueled by uh vicodin and hot flash
medicine pretty much whatever's in her
purse yeah yeah
it's like you run you can run one of
those cars on vegetable oil yeah same
deal which is also in her purse yes
good tanning it's a big purse solution
it helps get the benzos down as well yes
and we by the way we have an exclusive
gingersnap spoke with someone in the the
taiwanese military oh good as well and
uh what's going on there on the ground
in taiwan we've talked about how taiwan
is very different from ukraine taiwan
matters to the united states
strategically if you guys understand
what goes on with chipsets and
technology um so there is a lot at play
here that being said of course i want
pelosi to to arrive and hopefully get
back to the united states safely because
if it comes down to picking commie
pieces of trash i'll pick the one with
the american flag
so i side with pelosi over xi jinping um
she's scheduled to meet with the
taiwanese president uh
uh tsai can you win on wednesday i'm not
going to get nailed no no that was
perfect and this is the highest level
visit to taiwan since newt gingrich in
1997. so let me give you a timeline okay
i want to give you a timeline so that
you can feel like you're armed to
understand what's going on here and then
um hopefully provide some
some additional insight and some
exclusive information with some people
who are on the ground in taiwan but all
references are available at
livewithcrowder.com okay to be clear so
july 30th
houshi jen is a commentator for the
communist chinese party okay
and they have a propaganda outlet the
global times this is when he tweeted and
again the time here is july 30th he said
uh
if i guess i have to do you have to do
this if you was fighter jay to score
pelosi plane to taiwan it is an invasion
the people's liberation army don't you
know how they use that term the people's
liberation army while enslaving them the
people yeah
liberating them to be slaves for them no
no i don't feel liberated shut up you're
liberated i liberated you
would you rather be free and die
i liberated you into tiny shoes
very sexy
the people's liberation army has the
right to forcibly dispel pelosi's plane
and the u.s fighter jets including
firing warning shots and making
technical movement or obstruction if
ineffective then shoot them down well
it's nice to see that the chinese the
people's liberation army now has a
concept of rights
don't you know how the rights only apply
to violence yeah we have the right wait
wait you're saying you have the right to
shoot somebody else it's my god-given
right it's right to me
inalienable too
but not your citizens and burn your
bible it's my right
freaking chinese not the people the
government government sucks some of the
people
just the weird people like of the owner
of the chinese restaurant have gone for
two years
and will never give me an extra napkin
or some free sriracha it's like they're
weird about that and then sometimes with
duck sauce you're like what
you got it right you're gonna bring me
one oh you're gonna educate me on your
right to duck sauce it's my right it's
my right to kill you no i just want duck
sauce no shoe no shoes no shirt no
service i don't like you no service you
made me take off my shoes sometimes
you're kind of confused you're like
do you want to make money
no
i'm like your most regular customer
in the back there's pandas and nine
trafficked kids yeah that often happens
kidding joking but probably so uh august
1st again give me the timeline a
speculation mounted that pelosi would
visit um
the chinese officials then threatened
there's been an escalation taking place
more retaliation it's the right and the
anticipated visit of speaker pelosi is
generating accusations that the u.s
supports taiwanese sovereignty
if speaker
visits taiwan said the chinese foreign
affairs spokesman
it would grossly interfere in china's
internal affairs
he warned the chinese oh he wouldn't
want that to happen sit idly by
whatever will you do without your
internal affairs
it's just more saber-rattling here's the
thing we don't need to
and i don't want to go to war the
problem is we are so beholden to china
for so many reasons and most of them are
unnecessary when people were warning
about china's going to be the next
superpower right this was everyone on
wall street because they wanted it to be
now i don't have a problem
with people using you know for example
we can't get an american manufacturer
for mugs it's not possible right now
yeah so i understand that some
manufacturing has to take place and by
the way manufacturing made in the usa
doesn't necessarily mean that it's
better but the idea that we are now
beholden to china and a big part of this
is because of the alliances that have
been created and what do you do do you
talk down do you stare down china and
have a leg to stand on when you declared
the w-h-o and so did youtube and
facebook and twitter to be an
authoritative source
on the pandemic who who hid
china's complicity with
the beginning of the pandemic yeah and
then you turn around and say hey by the
way china you better step in line like
oh no oh what are you gonna count to
three yeah this was donald trump's whole
point he said we've been handling the
china situation wrong for decades now
and now we're getting to a place where
china's gonna become more powerful more
interconnected and it makes it more
impossible
to go to a place like taiwan without
having to worry about being shot down
right and uh beijing's u.n
representative uh uh shang shun also
stated that uh this pelosi this visit is
provocative and if pelosi insists on
making it then china will take firm and
strong measures to safeguard our
national sovereignty and territorial
integrity
we allow no one to cross this red line
with her tigger bitties let's take over
well we'll do like like 100 meter dash
yeah it's not chess cross front line
it's torso no she can bring her to go
bitty's across ryan yeah
like a shelf
just
just hot titty across red line
everything goes behind red line nipple
we're fine yeah it's okay
the turkey's done
the turkey
well i mean there's a billion uh people
there i've heard yeah but but really
wait almost like there's an updated
account uh 19 billion 19 billion i got
you okay things happen how many are
really though into the fight
you know because that's really what they
always talk about how it's sort of a war
of numbers and it's like yeah but most
of them are attached to sewing machines
and have binded feet right yeah like
who's really going to be like yeah i
really want to stand up for this what's
like with the russian army right
everyone thought the russian army was
this myth of the russian military
they're a bunch of drunken conscripts
and we're seeing now what what a
difficult time they're having with a
very very small nation who's at least
enthused yeah
i mean this is a government that's
horrible to its people i can't imagine
them wanting to be on the side of this
right well okay on that note uh for
their part august 1st uh the bind
administration did in fact respond
completely incoherently here's the
national security spokesperson john
kirby
where he said that the united states
would not be intimidated
no new ground
that's a man who looks immediately
intimidated potential
the dude from spin city which oh by the
way has president
would change the status quo
and the world should reject any
prc effort to use it to do so
we will not take the bait or engage in
saber rattling
at the same time we will not be
intimidated
we will keep operating in the seas and
the skies of the western pacific as we
have for decades
we will continue to support cross-strait
peace stability support taiwan of course
defend a free and open indo-pacific
we'll come back
to maintain lines of communication with
beijing
all of that
is important and all of that
all of it is preserving the status quo a
couple of things first off that's a man
who's worn a suit his whole life who has
no idea how to wear a suit
ties tied improperly he doesn't if the
buttons are pulling would drive my mom
nuts because that's what she did just
his little jc penny combo he looks like
he's at his grandma's funeral right
exactly just picked it off like oh taupe
and taupe and taupe tie this works
perfectly this will be perfect for
graduation give me a corsage i'll be on
my way bro when they traded brand
jcpenney jcp yes it was a cool place to
hang out anymore all right so here's the
thing
he does not look like a man uh who is
not to be trifled with you trifle
but um he just said we will keep lines
open right communication with china hey
wasn't it joe biden saying that he would
not meet with putin
i think at first yes
is putin any worse than
than china when you look at what they're
doing when you look at their you look at
the chinese you'll use the term whatever
term prime minister president emperor
whatever term they want to use that day
the person who locks you away if you
utter the wrong syllables yeah that guy
no no as a matter of fact let's let's
assume that they're both totalitarian
[ __ ] let's assume both governments
are
china's at least you have to argue a
little more communist than current
russia why will you meet with one and
not the other where's all the grand
standing at this point because you can't
have that both ways
but by the way also here's something
more important
ukraine is a crap hole ukraine is a
corrupt crap hole so is russia taiwan is
not to the same degree right
and taiwan actually has a pretty
important national interest at stake
here for the united states
we have no dog in the fight of ukraine
but we want we want to make sure that we
talk to both sides okay so we said we
want to acknowledge taiwan's sovereignty
blah blah blah
that's him now but back then
or whenever i don't know when maybe in
the same i think it's in the same case
might have been the same the same press
conference he also said this repeatedly
said
that we oppose any unilateral changes to
the status quo from either side
we have said that we do not support
taiwan independence
and we have said that we expect
cross-strait differences to be resolved
by peaceful means
well crap is it a lanyard or a rape
whistle
well the thing is his rape whistle just
calls more rapists
it's called the party planner
it just notifies everyone of the moby
festival
not that you can see a whole lot with
but i think pelosi's plane just landed
in taiwan oh can we see let's go right
now live to cnn
it's got the american flag at the very
least did president biden call her to
call off it's like a decal yeah
it'll be about half an hour before they
wake her up and get her off the plane
but
president vladimir putin as he
brazenly violated the interior
territorial integrity of of ukraine in
an ongoing invasion
the guy who wakes up
substance china's claims for territorial
integrity when it comes to taiwan taiwan
today regardless of the one china policy
is is a functioning democracy a vibrant
economy supplies some 80 percent of the
world's semiconductors
i mean does it have a leg to stand on
china short leg
jim what you described is accurate and
then our goal is to keep it that way uh
to the extent that we provoke
china into seeking
uh reunification by coercion
uh then we are putting a peril of the
peace and prosperity that has enabled
taiwan to become
that effective now here's the thing i
want you to
sort of go along with me here if that
confused you it confused me because you
just said nothing if we're talking about
provoking
are you condemning pelosi for visiting
taiwan or are you saying that china is
in the wrong because they're trying to
provoke a war he's not being clear by
design this is why old media is dying
well this is why this policy has been
terrible for so long what he just said
doesn't make any sense china has a
policy that they are reunifying with
them and that taiwan is a part of china
right there is no difference in their
mind right now and it's like oh we don't
want to poke the bear and just let's
maintain the status quo and make the
problem harder to solve later for
somebody else to deal with right that's
why we're here today talking about this
and by the way i had no idea that that
we actually had an island so close
that's part of taiwan it's five miles
off the shore they have a small island
right there like what do you say to
those guys be like they just take that
yeah we can't defend that look at that
look at the little arrows that's part of
that's taiwan as well right that was the
first island that they actually fled to
when the the government was flying china
like ah you guys sorry well if you also
look at the rest of the islands as it
goes up you know through uh up toward
japan yeah look at those it really is
it's a very quick march for china if
they take over taiwan we talked about
that at length with ginger snap who
lived in a very long time now here's the
deal he just said can we play clip d one
more time play clip d one more time so
you can just see
how firmly they've taken a stand here in
this administration repeatedly said
we oppose any unilateral changes to the
status quo from either side
we have said that we do not support
taiwan independence
and we have said that we expect
crosstalk didn't you just say you
recognize their sovereignty
again if this is confusing to you it's
by design this for the same reason that
people hated donald trump yeah you are
confused right now
because donald trump would say no look
taiwan's its own china go screw
yourselves cheddar cheddar virus i'm
sorry wolf chad of uh rest you create
little limericks just a piss em off yeah
get the guy who dyes his hair with
nestle quick to go alert the chest
it's hershey's damn it hey that's what i
do get it right this is so stupid
what do you do when you are this
administration this is what you do you
speak out of both sides of your mouth
and you make no sense and this is
exactly what should be expected from an
administration who by the way they can't
they have their dick in a ringer because
they have been worshipping the who
remember that is for a while it was the
only authoritative source and the reason
was because the imperial college of
london's study that said two point
whatever million people in the united
states would be killed in the first four
months they had to right they had to
disregard that and so the only
authoritative source they had left on
youtube on facebook on twitter you can
check all the references at larger
credit.com go on your time machine go
back to the videos back then some of
them some of the episodes were removed
the only one left was like oh all we
have left is the who that was the only
authoritative source yeah that's why you
thought
that the the coronavirus originated in
my god nature
so this is an administration who
worshipped at the feet of the w-h-o-y
build back better they want to be part
of an international government
and now well what do they do the who
keep in mind this is the same
organization who also just like their
little uh expert there refused
to acknowledge taiwan's existence
remember this the who considered
taiwan's membership
take off your shirt
hello
i couldn't hear your question okay yeah
let me let me let me repeat the
questions let's move to another one then
right
i'm actually curious on talking about
taiwan as well on taiwan's case
that is bone chilling oh yeah and how
could he not hear i haven't boxed his
ears yet
so oh we'll just move to another
question
yeah that's odd what a weird response
you can do that yeah
i had no idea you could do that do you
remember the time when these doctors
that were trying to submit papers to the
who to actually help and say hey we have
some information that you guys may want
to take a look at and they were like ah
we can't because you don't know what
island doesn't exist those are enemies
of democracy enemies
enemies of accurate information online
just like all of us are more so enemies
of the state than uh heads of al qaeda
in case you didn't understand the rule
we need to keep an eye on domestic
extremism and misinformation trust the
who let's go to august 2nd again going
through this timeline here the people's
liberation army i almost can't say it
without throwing up a little bit um
they're now uh mobilizing
of course as uh pelosi prepares to
depart malaysia right now this is
happening where she's just she's walking
they're showing her landing walking down
gingerly this is when people talk about
how the gop is the party of old guys
this is the party of people who can't
walk down steps
or up
newt gingrich at the time of course a
republican during the clinton presidency
will ripley he is in taipei for us
tell us how
taiwan has been preparing for this
well they certainly haven't been telling
us anything publicly on the record
reportable in sight you know why
wouldn't they trust cnn you know
the most trusted you're the most trusted
name in news i mean you guys said you
were but didn't they not did they not
hear james or old jones give the memo
weird they're saying well uh newt
gingrich did this this was the same kind
of thing i was like just 25 years ago do
you guys not understand how much has
happened in 25 years right like you're
saying that this is normal this is the
third ranking person in our government
going right
this is in thailand how did i get here
this is bold you don't have ladyboys do
you
shows up with boys or boys boys gotten
it all wrong
so uh and this morning's uh the china's
on uh envoy to pakistan
uh uh libyan tweeted that both of china
both oh this is what i look forward to
both of china's combat-ready carriers by
the way for comparison i think they have
the second most the united states has
the most with 11
11 active one of them's being used for
top gun three
so ten that's a fair point yeah
another one of them is val kilmer's
smoking room so nine but the point is
china has both forms of their combat
ready where uh combat ready carriers uh
right now uh having left portions
and here's a quick video from wechat
showing that amphibious vehicles are on
the move to uh the island that you just
xiaomi
yeah so where they are is six miles it
was wrong six miles from kenmon which is
part of
taiwan great six miles not very far not
very far can men's house pronounce
kenmon so uh shimon is where they were
oh china and kenmon is the island i
thought you were correcting me when i
said chairman right now that's not how
they pronounce the x's no no i wouldn't
do that
i would never fact-check you i played
mortal kombat
yep
that's just six miles apart yeah
think about that first think about how
terrifying that is for a second yeah
it's kind of like saying we want to
continue the status quo with iran in
their quest to destroy the state of
israel and say that they don't have a
right to exist right like oh well that's
a good status quo just keep going i
guess um and here's something else too i
wanted to get to this is an exclusive
gingersnap did some good work here um
the taiwanese actually seemed to be
welcoming this visit so uh when asked
about it
and uh this is someone who junior snap
here lane um i guess made a connection
with yeah uh a taiwanese reservist his
name is uh bruce lew said the rewards of
the visit outweighed the risk and that
and we try to get him on video but this
is a direct quote we'll probably get an
interview with him soon
he said even though we have not faced
any war in my generation and we don't
have enough training as a compulsory
military personnel i still believe most
of us will stand to defend our country
freedom and the way we
live
that's a big deal again these people are
motivated there's a there's a huge
difference between people who are forced
to fight for a government who they know
will still hold them under their thumb
after the war is over and people who are
fighting a war to maintain their freedom
big difference
big difference
not to mention uh taiwan is no joke
people will be surprised as to the kind
of a fight that they can put up they
know how to use their terrain they've
been preparing it's it's sort of like uh
to give you an example uh joe lewis
there's a dog right my dog uh this is a
dog argentino now
can dogs take out generally boars no or
even like rhodesian rhodesian ridgebacks
they're designed to hunt lions yeah can
a dog take out a lion no
would joe lewis dwell with a lion no of
course not a lion would absolutely mull
him would rhodesian ridge back to as
well with a bore not as well because you
don't have to be the best at everything
joe lewis the doug argentino they're
bred to go out capture a bore or a
mountain lion by the neck and pin it
they specifically have loose fur breath
in their neck you've seen this if you
never grab joe lewis by the neck and
then he can just sort of do a 360 like
how did that happen yeah that's that if
an animal specifically a mountain lion
or a boar grabs his neck he can rotate
around and pin that animal so this is an
animal that is bred for a specific
purpose and that's why sometimes you'll
be surprised like how can a dog take on
a wolf like an irish wolf pound how can
i think dogs are fascinating because
there really are perfect examples of how
we've bred certain species into
existence for a very very limited
purpose there's something called the
life budget you gain it somewhere you
lose it somewhere else doesn't mean that
taiwan could handle a war for example
with russia that they could handle a war
with any military but they know how to
defend that strip of land along their
coast from china as effectively as
anyone on earth because that is what
they have had to prepare for yeah
they don't need as much help from the
united states as let's say ukraine
they still will
and we just need to send in one or two
of our
11 carriers
it's hysterical we could send in two to
match china's and still have nine to
spare we'll just let them hang out the
next great superpower yeah screw you you
little pricks
[Laughter]
the government no pun intended no i just
no well
but even then there's a small group of
pro-unification protesters again this
happens everywhere in somewhat free
societies taiwan they're demonstrating
against a visit holding signs calling
pelosi an american witch well they're
not necessarily wrong about everything i
guess at that point even though
oh this segment is terrible it's times
like these i'm confused how any of these
guys have a woman i know these morons
have nothing to offer a lady well i
wouldn't say nothing oh why is that
landler well at least after being with
them they'll make a happy widow
it's the worst investment i've ever made
and we can't take it hurtful but we'll
keep uh we'll keep following here pelosi
she's in taiwan right now she's walking
with her her brittle stilts across cnn
screen by the way hey please share the
show if you're watching this it's the
best way uh to make sure that people see
it share it sharing is caring
youtube algorithm if you try to search
like
louder with crowder abortion so if you
try and search louder with crowd or
taiwan you won't find it so try and
search
spaghetti bones yes by the way something
really funny so so china's not just
sitting down and taking this they're
doing some saber rattling but they're
also kind of being a little petty they
actually crashed all the government's uh
computers for taiwan so they launched a
cyber attack against them china did yeah
china did uh and then you know the the
taipei towers the taipei 101 uh which at
one point was the tallest building in
the world it's definitely the tallest in
taiwan had uh some you know nice words
we welcome speaker pelosi we love the
united states all that stuff so we're
getting a good reception over there
fantastic there's parts of the world
they tell us to go home we should
probably take that advice and let them
deal with their own stuff there's type a
i think it's taipei 101. how many
taiwanese asses do you think are just
pressed up against those windows right
now
please press in a lot of hams i really
hope so
i would say how many windows don't have
exactly it's a better question
that's the one guy with monkey box
one guy come on one guy all right this
brings us to the monkey pox uh situation
let me ask you before i move on pause
this if you're watching the archive
pause it
what do you think the statistics are now
on monkey pox that it's been declared a
global emergency emergency what trends
do you think exist
don't
don't
guys
the suspense is killing me
i hope it'll last all right
the media
this is sort of i'm giving you a hint
because the media usually would they
usually do the opposite of what's true
yeah yeah not always
no
pretty much
they'd rather not characterize monkey
pox
as a gay disease
they don't want to do that
again place your bets i guess cnn didn't
quite get the memo
tell us how you learned you had monkey
pox yeah so i actually work in the
infectious diseases space i'm a phd
candidate doing research so with that
and being a gay man in new york city i
feel like i was monkeybox was on my mind
a little bit more than your average
person perhaps
your phd is that what it is that's what
you call your vietnamese screw hammock
let's go let's go i want to watch this
again there's so many things wrong with
this it's a penis hardening degree yes
let's go back with this
tell us how you learned you had monkey
pot yeah so i actually work in the
infectious diseases
i work in the infectious diseases space
irrelevant that's not why you're
concerned about monkey pox
that's that's not at all why you were
concerned about monkey pox continue
playing also do you work or do you play
yeah she candidated doing research
that also is not relevant as to why you
are concerned about monkey pops like i
work with infectious diseases erroneous
i also have a phd candidate erroneous
why are you really concerned with monkey
pox keep playing with that and being a
gay man in new york city i feel like oh
there it is there we go working hard or
hardly working there it is that's the
primary concern that'd be like me saying
i'm concerned about youtube removing the
show and censoring our content why
because i was raised in montreal yeah is
that the well also because i host a show
on youtube where we say controversial
things that go against the group oh
that's the piece of information that's
relevant so he starts off with i worked
on the infectious diseases and i'm a
doctor and uh no it's because you would
it's because you just went to an enya
concert and spit-roasted
a kenyan pirate
well yeah it's like saying i'm a
professional baseball player but i'm
mostly concerned because i've had
unprotected homosexual sex with so very
many people yes exactly that means
you're gay well i think so
so let's go here and there's they're so
irresponsible if you work in that
category
i mean it's really you should be at the
top of your game going guys right guys
all of you right let's just let's let's
just pull them all out for a second we
need to discuss this for example we
gotta have a little powwow guys
different kind of powwow
for monkey fox you just you just look at
everyone like i guess you're not at risk
and you have a picture of sophia around
you check their pants you're like all
right have you seen what monkey pox will
do to if the other half if the other
half of us could stand up and just face
each other i think we have something to
talk
and you know what you think they'd want
to here's the issue okay people say
you're just reading homophobic no we're
not no we're not cool because here here
is the unholy alliance it goes back to
the who goes to of course tedros there
at who yeah goes to uh fouchy who said
one in five heterosexual couples would
be affected by aids people like goes to
gavin newsom these people have lied to
you repeatedly they did the exact same
thing with aids
and they did the same thing with covid
by the way so one was disproportionately
affecting homosexuals here in the united
states the other was not covid but they
lied about all of it due to political
expediency so let's go back to then okay
on july 23rd
by the way 99 of all uh monkeybox gay
outside of africa but we'll get to that
in a second july 23rd the wh i felt i
felt like i needed to say that just in
case people were like was this baseless
claim july 23rd who director general uh
uh
director general is the tedros i don't
know i don't know how to say his other
name dr tedros he declared monkey pox a
global health emergency so in short
we have an outbreak that has spread
around the world rapidly
through new models of transmission
about which we understand too little and
which meets the criteria in the
international health regulations
for all of these reasons
i have decided that the global monkey
box outbreak represents
a public health emergency of
international concern
new modes of transmission
don't have anal sex with infected
lesions well with uh that we don't know
a lot about right
personally i personally don't know a lot
about that particular mode yeah totally
bring in plenty of babies to cure the
problem right like in the past well this
is what happens outside of africa uh you
can bring us up actually right here uh
the who um
that says 99 of cases outside of africa
are among homosexual men okay outside of
africa because what happened is one of
these african men came back from the
techno music festival and didn't want to
tell his hot wife
were you back at a moby concert no no
[Laughter]
were you listening to sandstorm no
you've brought some shame into our mud
flintstone house so
um the panel by the way the who panel
after tedros
they were consulted
they didn't declare that it was an
emergency they said ah we don't really
think so and tedros overruled the panel
so let's be clear about this with the
who
it's not some kind of a representative
no republic a democracy what tedro says
goes and if tedros doesn't want to have
an uncomfortable conversation with his
wife you all now have to worry about
monkey pox yeah and by the way that's
the first time he has overruled the
recommendation of the panel
that we know first time
shouldn't be doing that that we know of
you don't think he threatens people
behind closed doors but it'd be a shame
if you got monkey pox
[Laughter]
[Music]
i don't know maybe like a like a fire
started just scraping off skin shavings
no all right so that was that in what
looks like fruity pebbles right yeah
now let's go to now on uh july 28th
close enough the who issued guidance to
uh homosexual men
to quit being and here's the thing it's
not that you're gay just to be clear
it's not that everyone who's gay is at
risk
if you are a monogamous gay couple
you are also not at risk it is the
sexual patterns that we all know and
statistically are undeniable have taken
place within the gay community they tend
to be far more promiscuous the reason is
because there's no woman to say uh no
and this all stems from one festival and
the reason that it's it's not that can
only spread in the gay community it's
that has been it has been largely
contained to the gay community because
of patience zero okay just to be clear
so the who issued guidance to gay men to
stop being the specific gay men not all
gay men to stop being such degenerates
this is an outbreak that can be stopped
if countries communities and individuals
inform themselves
take the risk seriously and take the
steps needed to stop transmission
and protect
vulnerable groups
the best way to do that is to reduce the
risk of exposure okay
that means making safe choices for
yourself and others
[Music]
for men who have sex with men
this includes for the moment reducing
your number of sexual partners
for the people considering sex with new
partners
and exchanging contact details with any
new partners to enable follow-up if
needed
okay so that means no more anonymous
orgies like the darklings festival that
started the entire outbreak well you
would
very astute but incorrect because that's
too much to ask let's go to now san
francisco
did not even cancel its annual queer
bdsm festival on july 31st oh the san
francisco treat yes
and let's let's keep in mind by the way
uh well a couple things the following
day by the way california after that so
that's the bdsm festival yeah then
california declared what a state of
emergency due to the monkey pox outbreak
ah
and we actually sent our correspondent
lane for live coverage uh of the post
event fallout
jeff we're gonna need to make some new
hires yeah i hope he's okay but i
wouldn't count on it so let's be clear
about this in case you wondered as to
what are you guys pointing to me do
something with china i had a quick thing
okay you're going to love this about
tedros then i'm going to let you make
your point here so i actually found
something that i think you'll enjoy
there's a quote by ted rose in an
article here if we can pull that overlay
up that we were talking about earlier
he's actually worried that the
thing that is spread by gay men having
anal sex with other
men who have sex with men men who have
sex with men and i underlined the
important part here um
it could go from infected people to the
animal population oh my gosh
we've talked about that we thought that
the monkeys were giving it to us
aids we thought it was just
dean not dean's milk i'm like okay how
uh
maybe talk about that that mode of
transmission we'd also like to say we'd
like you to not have anal sex with uh
you know animals i mean i thought i
wouldn't have to say this but apparently
we do uh apparently we have to do a lot
the only ones safe
from monkey pox sodomy are women yeah
i wonder if lamb skin condoms work only
if you have sex with a lamb it's like it
will live in the animal population and
then somehow make it back to the human
population it's i swear to you it's in
the quote by the way new york new york
and who 99
are from
are men and then 99 of them are men who
have sex with men in case you were
wondering either of them are rottweilers
right
shaggy
i would have gotten away with it too
rhymes with shaggy
[Laughter]
in case you were wondering as to whether
this is politically motivated let's put
this in context
covet
you were all forced into lockdowns in
california indefinitely businesses shut
down we upended the economy created the
the worst ripple effect for a generation
of americans that we have ever seen
in our lifetime you were forced to wear
masks which by the way of course we now
know didn't really make any difference
we have the petri dishes you can look at
the different states didn't make any
difference whatsoever neither did
lockdowns you were forced to have your
id scanned or your your vaccine passport
if we look across countries canada
europe australia and even states like
new york okay so this happened for all
of you
with monkey pox right now where 99
are transmitted between gay men
they won't even pardon my language
cancel their gay san francisco [ __ ] fest
and you think they're doing this for you
[Laughter]
does that put a finer point on it i'm
sorry but just think about this for a
second instead they'll walk down the
entire state the day after they have sex
with chokers on floats
well come on there's tourism money
coming in that's true it's true this is
all another ploy by big gay
how many
you mentioned every maid at a hotel is
just like why did they why did i come
here
do i clean the sheets just burn them i
don't know you can put them in the
tarpon anything i saw from the cartel is
not happening
i would say cardio i would kill to just
see a hair on a turtle
i've never seen so much blood on the
walls
july 31st the bdsm festival
goes off without a hitch the next day
it's a state of emergency the state of
california think about that i had to
wait 99
of the transmissions would be taking
place at that bdsm festival and instead
the rest of you deal with the
ramifications remember when fauci said
one in five heterosexual couples will be
affected by aids remember when he said
that kids could get aids uh if they were
in a household with parents we all these
references are available you can go to
your commercials about that stuff yeah i
remember they were haunting yeah and you
know what now i think they kind of admit
it uh and by that i'm just making sort
of an inference based on the commercials
for the prev pill
well even with monkey pox in california
they were like look it's not all gay
people see these two kids got it and
it's like really we're just gonna
stop the investigation at that huh right
well i'm actually i'm not surprised
about new york and california declaring
a state of emergency i'm surprised by
illinois
yeah they also declared one i was like
they have a lot of farmland and
those cattle are really huge just a
bunch of somali pirates creeping like
cartoons
those sheep were dressed provocatively
stephen
and this is also by the way i know and
everything that we've just said you can
take to the bank it's all true you can
look at the statistics we have the
references available at
lightofscanner.com however sometimes
what we do is just meant to be
entertaining and that's where when we do
our tour you know in the fall you can
say whatever you want on stage i started
this two weeks ago when i was in spokane
a bit about monkey pox uh and uh it was
way more offensive then
than it is now i was almost like he was
almost like comedy nostradamus
look i gotta i gotta let you in on
something okay here uh some of the
things that i say up here
they're not true
they're just jokes
like that bit about going to zambia
adopting kids that never happened i
wouldn't be caught dead in zambia
come back with monkey boxing [ __ ]
oh okay sorry sickle cell whatever
offends you more i don't care
jew polio takes your pick
[Applause]
monkey pox yeah the who they just
declared it enough that's the newest
national international health emergency
monkey pops
and the new york the new york bureau of
health they just you can research this
yourself they just release statistics 99
of people who have monkey pox are men
99 of them are gay sorry they label them
as men who have sex with men
like we don't know what that means
look i'm just saying if we want to solve
the monkey pox equation it's not rocket
science just quarantine the gay people
[Applause]
hey i'm joking but i'm not
i'm not
be easy when they fly in go through
customs basic questionnaire have you
attended any techno music festivals
recently
have sex with the somali pirates
what are your thoughts on share simple
stuff
and everyone with a lisp straight to a
fema camp
now i wouldn't have been able to say
that on this show
because youtube would take it as though
i meant it seriously right
though i wouldn't be opposed to sending
people with a lisp to fema camps i don't
know you can comment below i don't know
i i i'm still conflicted on it but uh of
course you can go and see dave and i
live the big fall torch these big venues
that i've never done before they do
looking forward to but also
we've never i don't think well you have
done when you open for dave chappelle
but like six thousand seats that uh
phoenix yeah i've never done them as a
as the main act there with you on the
16th and then houston the 17th and then
you are in dayton ohio uh this friday
through saturday the funny bone that's
correct yeah we would say something to
gerald before we leave so look
what's the takeaway today a couple of
things
china sucks
taiwan hopefully uh maintains their
independence and uh how does this relate
to you personally we never want to leave
you without um some of the glean from
this that you say okay how can i change
my day-to-day life there's not that much
that you need to change today
unless you're having uh group sex with
strange men
on a regular basis maybe just try and
keep that to a minimum and then let's
really try and build some momentum with
that we're gonna go play pokemon or hate
symbol is it pokemon or racial slurs or
racial slur oh thank god this is not
here on youtube this is for mug club
only another 45 minutes of show today
youtube piss off
[Music]